[Music]  et has the exclusive photos of Janet  Jackson now and about for the first time  since the birth of her son my family  means everything wearing glasses her  hair piled casually on top of her head  the 50 year old new mom stuff - do a  little shopping for her son Issa she  gave birth just three weeks ago Janet  was snapped exiting London's baby  boutique in blue almonds  rocking an oversized fur cape over baggy  black pants with black sneakers the shop  wouldn't comment on what Janet bought  but the store is also a favorite of Kate  Middleton ET learned in October that  Janet was expecting her first child at  50 years old my husband and I are  planning our family  you